you are so brilliant in this i mean
you're always brilliant in everything
you do but you are so brilliant in this
you captured williams internal struggle
so well
you made him like you gave him humanity
so i wanted to know when you
were getting into this character because
obviously on the outside
an fbi informant going against his own
people
looks a certain way but you found a way
to make him so real
and and likeable in a way so what was
the process like for you and
understanding him and creating him
um well i had to deal with my
uh own ego and my own judgments
yeah we had about you know only thing i
knew about him was that he supplied the
floor plans that ended up getting
chairman fred hampton uh
assassinated in that he did an interview
for eyes on the prize
i'd only seen the clip at first i was
like yeah this guy
but as i got into it and i dived in
i realized that i wouldn't be able to
play the character completely if i
judged him so i didn't get i had to let
go all that stuff and um
i find the humanity in it all and uh
find the feeling
when i watch the long-form version of
the interview
appeared to me that um he
he had uh he felt bad about what he did
you know so i wanted to take that little
part and um
you know sort of uh i guess like expound
upon it
yeah did you get any reaction from his
family at all
for your role oh man i don't know i
don't know i
i haven't really had my ear to the wind
on it but uh
yeah i just hope that everything's
balanced you know
i never want to when you're playing real
people you don't want to
make them out to be you know i don't
know
you want to just be honest as honest as
you can be
and my intention is definitely not to
you know create more disarray i just
want to help tell the story you know so
i hope that they can appreciate the
story and appreciate the truth and
honesty that we put into it
and um that's the most oh i was waiting
i was like it's gotta happen
because you're serious but you have like
a really great sense of humor so i was
like i'm waiting for this thing to fall
off his head
i caught it though i got it ah you did
you did of course you did of course you
did
um if you don't get nominated for
something i will fight
someone i don't know who i'm gonna fight
but someone's gonna get fought you were
that brilliant in this
do you care about reviews when people
are saying like
he was incredible all this stuff like do
you read that or
you don't want to know well some of it i
yeah some of it i come into contact with
them you know
i appreciate the praise i and i i want
people to
enjoy and watch the film and you know i
hope that people can appreciate all the
work that we put
into this so it's nice to see that you
know
um at the same time i don't think that
it's uh
super important what you know um
critiques coming like
you know we give it to the world right
like so we put our love into it
and we give it out onto the world now
it's yours you know like we ain't really
you know it's not up to us anymore it's
like the people you know
and that's the most important thing
that's what we tell stories for like it
really ain't about my own
satisfying ego or whatever you know my
ego is satisfied when i surpass my own
self and my own expectations personally
but
it doesn't really you know it's not it
doesn't live in movies you know like
there's more
like personal achievements but um but
i'm happy to see the great reception i'm
happy to see that people
you know like the movie and they like my
performance they like the cast
they like what we've done and the
director and i'm happy about that
you know that's great
you